there's a very interesting new study
called chronic low calorie sweetener use
and risk of abdominal obesity among
older adults this is by Chia char del
Tanaka and others and what this study
looked at was let's look at people who
use low-calorie sweeteners instead of
sugar and let's look at whether that's
actually something that correlates with
more effectively controlling weight
measured by abdominal obesity and what
the study did it was a longitudinal
study it looked at thousands and
thousands of measurements and food diary
records with detailed information on
sugar versus low calorie sweetener
consumption etc etc they had a median
follow-up time of 10 years I won't get
into every detail about the study but
needless to say we are linking to it and
you can check it out and what the study
determined was that low calorie
sweetener use was independently
associated with heavier relative weight
a larger waist and a higher prevalence
and incidence of abdominal obesity
suggesting that low calorie sweetener
use may not be an effective means of
weight control relative to sugar use now
number one correlation versus causation
one might read the study and say oh well
you use low calorie sweeteners instead
of sugar and you end up heavier or more
overweight that's not what the study is
saying what it's saying is that those
who use low calorie sweeteners instead
of sugar tend to have a higher BMI or be
more obese but that isn't necessarily
because of the sweetener use right and
the the study says that they controlled
for other variables because what we
really need to determine is are
individuals who are already heavier more
obese more likely to use low calorie
sweeteners than sugar but that's not
actually why they are obese so that's I
think a very very fair question but my
thing has always been Pat use a little
sugar or get used to not using sugar so
like for example with coffee
I used to put quite a bit of sugar in my
coffee and my mom for example uses a ton
of artificial sweetener and I said you
know it doesn't really make sense to me
I think I'm just gonna start putting in
less less sugar into my coffee and I got
used to that and now I don't drink
coffee with sugar at all that seems more
logical to me than just making things
super sweet with artificial sweeteners
which many many of which have been shown
to not be healthy I think a lot of
people just just go to these options
things like diet soda Splenda equal
because they think it's the healthier
operative yeah and their doctors may
tell them to embrace a low sugar diet
and they think well you know I don't
have I don't have to give up these
drinks that I like I can still continue
to have them it can still be yeah no
doubt about it and we saw this
phenomenon with the so called low-fat
snack craze where you had cookies that
were low fat but instead had other
chemicals in them where you saw other
types of snacks that were low-fat potato
chips that were low fat etc etc number
one it's unclear that the replacement of
those fats with chemicals and other
substances is not worse for you and
additionally we know that people tend to
over indulge in foods that they perceive
to be healthier so yeah I don't remember
if it was snack Wells or what experiment
was done so I'm kind of low-fat cookie
and people would just eat way way more
because they were like hey it's low-fat
I can eat twice as much yeah I think
it's more of a marketing thing than in
any interest in protecting people's
health yep I totally agree with you and
very very similar findings bottom line
if you're having a weight issue it's far
healthier to for example ditch the soda
altogether than switching from two cokes
a day to do diet cokes a day if you are
looking to reduce the amount of sugar
you're consuming I would say get used to
stuff being not as sweet as opposed to
switching to equal or Splenda or
whatever artificial sweetener it is that
you're using and the science does seem
to bear that out